All right, let's hear from some folks in the
audience via The David Pakman Show discord,
which you can find at David Pakman dotcom
slash discord.
Let's start today with James from New York.
Is that is this is this James M.D. from New
York?
Are you a doctor?
Oh, boy, James.
Oh, yeah.
How are you?
Good, how are you?
I'm doing well.
Yeah, so I called them before sort of asking
about why it seems like this whole government
seems to be missing the forest for the trees.
I thought you gave a great answer.
I have a question for you about it.
Seems like Biden is just sort of entering
the game, trying to play let's be friends
with everybody.
Let's show unity almost like letting the Republicans
sort of like undercut his positions, give
less for covid, not do basically the best
for the American person.
And why isn't Biden just ram all of these
things down their throats to basically get
the general public to be like, wow, health
insurance is better, my food is better and
cheaper.
I actually did get money underbite as he seem
to want to compromise on all this stuff, to
pretend like there's unity when the Republicans
are in power, they put all the Supreme Court
justices on and say, tough break, you lost
the election.
Well, I think we still need a little more
time to know which path he's taking.
You're completely right that Joe Biden has
been talking about unity.
He invited Republicans to the White House
to meet about the covid bill on Monday night.
I am fine with Biden talking about unity and
talking to Republicans.
If, as you say, in the end, he just goes forward.
And from what we heard after that Monday meeting
from Jen Psaki, the White House press secretary,
Democrats are just planning to move ahead
with the covid relief bill as designed with
the one point nine trillion.
I believe it's actually perfect if Biden eventually
is just going to say we're sticking with the
one point nine and it's what Democrats go
for, put these Republicans in a position to
actually vote no on it because that covid
relief bill is popular with many Republican
voters.
Tens of millions of Republican voters, I don't
believe call the bluff of the Republicans.
I don't believe that every Republican is going
to vote against the one point nine trillion
because they know many of their constituents
want that and they like that bill.
So if what Joe Biden does is talk about unity,
talk about compromise, meet with Republicans
and then not go forward with the one point
nine, I will be as pissed as it sounds like
you're going to be if this is all just Biden
doing what he said he would do, but then he's
still going to stick to what he wants.
I'm fine with it.
We'll probably know in the next few days which
of the two it's going to be.
Yeah, that's pretty fair.
I just I would rather him he could play the
let's have unity together, but I just think
he needs to ram these policies down their
throats to show, you know, the average American
especially, you know, it seems like the biggest
class that's voting conservative these days
is uneducated voters that just to show them,
here's the proof in the pudding.
Here's your money here.
I gotcha.
Yeah, I don't disagree.
Let's let's see if he does it.
James from New York, appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.
Let's go next to Terrence from Gloster, Terrence
from Gloucester.
You're on the air.
Hi, David, how's it going?
Can you hear me OK?
I can hear you fine.
So I don't know if you remember me, but we
spoke a couple of months ago when I called
in under the single letter Pseudonymity to
talk about the decent federalism project,
which was my project on Twitter, at least
the project to advocate for distributing some
power currently held by the federal government
down to a five part framework of regions of
the US.
I know you take a lot of calls, but do you
roughly remember our conversation or anything
we talked about?
Yes.
OK, so the YouTube video on your channel,
I think is called Should the Country Be Divided
into Regions?
And I think it's still a worthy video for
people to check out.
But so I remember from our conversation and
correct me if I'm wrong, I understood you
as having said towards the end of our discussion
that you were open, at least in principle,
to a more regional approach to governance
in the United States.
Does that sound like a fair characterization
of what you said?
I don't remember exactly.
But did you have a question today?
Yeah.
So so I guess my big question is whether you
see the events of, like, recent days, recent
months as affirming or complicating the idea
of regionalizing our system of governance
in the way we've discussed before in terms
of the stop the steal, the 17 state attorneys
general from the south and central parts of
the country that basically wanted to overturn
the election, as well as sort of the coalition
that Joe Biden built for to to win the election.
I have to tell you, I don't think the events
of the last few months to me suggest that
regionalization for governance would be better
or worse.
I don't I don't think it really strikes me
as something to think about in those terms
one way or the other.
OK, fair enough that that was really my only
question.
All right, very good.
Terrence from Gloucester, great to hear
from
you again.